[Musique]
la fête s'est bien passé j'ai n'irai
jamais l'un d'eux portait agi d'être
femme en laine presse et il est beau et
bon je m'appelle simon et je suis comme
toi j'ai une famille normale tes amis
géniaux un lycée banal
qu'est ce que tu fais pas textos dans
les couloirs je ne peux pas laisser mes
étudiants à l'issue linder c'est mon
domaine
j'ai une vie parfaitement normal sauf
que j'ai un énorme secret de mise salut
sheikh blue je suis comme toi mais
personne c'est que je suis gay pierre
simon
c'est bon de savoir qu'un autre garçon
lisse et partage le même secret quand
est-ce que tu l'as eu cher blue il ya
une série de petites choses comme ma
première petite amie et je crois qu'ils
amoureuse de toi je reviens ça n'a pas
été mon heure de gloire je vous tends à
parler à quelqu'un dans blue j'en ai
parlé à personne
quoi qu'on en dise révéler aux autres ce
qu'on est et terrifiant abyss est la
plus sexy que j'ai jamais vu c'est pas
vraiment mon genre
pas parce que les noirs j'adore les
femmes noires enfin pas comme tu adores
toutes les femmes gèrent blue c'est très
injuste que seuls les gains doivent
faire leur coming out
imagine un peu il faut que je vous dise
quelque chose je suis hétéro j'aime les
filles quoi tu veux ma mort
[Musique]
on regarde tout de suite son ordinateur
quelqu'un publié teddy mail sur le blog
du lycée je regrette simon je peux plus
continuer c'est moi qui suis censée
décider où quand comment et qui le sait
et comment je peux le dire c'est quelque
chose qui m'appartient
c'est le genre de personne qui est
destiné mais tellement une personne qui
ça pourrait peut-être consistent so they
retenir sa respiration
tu toujours toi si mme matas déjà être
l'amour je sais pas je crois
cher blue je ne sais peut être ni tour
n'ont ni à quoi tu ressembles mais je
veux trouver
j'en peux plus de vivre dans un monde je
peux pas être qui je suis sorti avec moi
parce que tu trouves que je ressemble à
un garçon en fait j'ai rompu avec toi
parce que tu ne ressembles par ailleurs
d'accord merci dorion